covert cases are up again so what is
going on well latest data from the
office for national statistics show more
than 1.4 million people in the uk are
estimated to have had covid in the week
to the 9th of june that's up 43
on the previous week
let's put that in context these are the
weekly covered numbers since the start
of the year with a big peaks of the
original omicron variant ba1 and its
closely related sibling ba2 and the more
recent rise still modest but likely to
increase further why well it comes down
to a tug of war between the virus and
our immunity first the virus which has
continued to evolve there are two new
members of the omicron family call ba4
and ba5 they're even more infectious
leading to a recent rise in cases in
south africa and they're now spreading
in the uk the jubilee crowds might have
fueled transmission of course now
against all that you have waning
immunity statistics from the uk health
security agencies show that immediately
after the booster dose last winter the
vaccine was between 60 and 74 effective
at preventing omicron symptoms but after
20 weeks protection was in its words
negligible and having the virus doesn't
do much to protect against reinfection
either according to recent research by
imperial college so a combination of new
more infectious viruses and falling
immunity points to a summer surge of
covid
hospitalizations are already rising but
that's likely to be people testing
positive after they've been admitted for
other medical conditions
even if the vaccine doesn't stop
symptoms it's still 77 effective at
preventing serious disease even several
months after the booster and there's
been no rise so far in those needing a
ventilator because of covid but with
many businesses not least airlines and
the hospitality sector struggling to
find staff at the moment the last thing
they need is another surgeon kovid
increasing the number of people off sick